Today's topic. This is a video that was submitted by a viewer.
Let's take a look.
Who have a lot of money and you go broke and I've been there through the
struggle. And I personally feel that you have a legitimate reason to be broke.
And I have a validation to believe that you'll seek wealth again.
Then I'll hold you down. If you're broke, when I'm,
you don't stand a chance because what's broke to you.
What is defined broke?
You make less than double what I make less
than double. Yes. <laugh>.
Oh, you're right.
You're just mad. Cuz you're broke anymore.
Less than double what she's making. I just had to. Yeah.
What did you think broke meant before ni broke? Can't pay the bills. Right?
Can't pay the bills. I got no job. And I was like,
even then I was like, okay. Yeah, whatever. You know, what's interesting.
It's like, even if we made as much as her and we were equal broke,
we're still inferior in her head.
That was interesting being at the same level as her, but her us being a man.
We, yeah, that's interesting. So yeah. You're not equal. Yeah.
That's that's not a feminist. That's definitely not. We know that.
It's all good.
That being said it's because I've held broke men down.
I've been played by broke men. Okay. And personally it doesn't pay off.
So I won't do it again. And it is what.
It is. This was court for, if I'm gonna get played,
let it be by someone with a lot of money. You know, when you get hurt by people,
you start to look at
nonsensical reasons for the reason why you got hurt. Oh,
these didn't make enough money and they were cheaters.
So if I get rid of the fact that they don't make all enough money,
then maybe I'll find dude, who's gonna treat me. Right.
That's a stupid way.
Whether you get cheated on by a rich person or by a broke person,
you're still being left with nothing. Am I wrong?
It's funny because instead of figuring out,
why you getting cheat or why are you getting played by these people?
Why you go to these people? No, you know what,
let me not be accountable for how I,
you think I'm just gonna go for riches.
Well, my thing is also like men with more money, have more options,
which means that they're more likely to cheat.
And you also don't recognize how your behavior may come off as toxic and may
encourage more toxic people to come to you.
You are what you attract. Generally speaking, you know,
and I thing is to come down on her and mock her or, or basically do all this.
But I'm saying this is a bad way to get what you want.
Like girls who go after bad boys, very attractive, bad boys.
They find out it's not all up. It's made up to be, what do they do?
They settle on someone with less. Are you saying that they, they find.
Out that the bad boys they went for are actually, I don't know, uh, bad boys
<laugh> for life.
You did that. I imagine you. Woo. Here we go.
It's not hard to find someone who makes twice. What I make.
I personally track people who make like a whole spectrum. That being said,
if you are broke and I choose to deal with you, I will. Belile you.
It is what.
It is. Oh,
we went from toxic to toxic waste.
<laugh> that's what we did right there. First. It was toxic. I was like, I,
now you just toxic waste. You will.
Belitle them.
Ooh.
This is one of those girls that like,
they look cute until they open their mouth.
I'm too sober for this. Oh, that should do it.
Oh yeah. You know what she reminds me of. She reminds me of Kay, Michelle,
but a little bit more well spoken in this sense. I like, I just think this is a,
a person who's engaging in a bad form of self-preservation who is engaging in
behavior that thinks it gives her more control and more power when it really
just encourages us more negative, more negative loops.
It's like, yo, listen, if you want others to treat you well, generally speaking,
you have to treat them well,
generally speaking doesn't mean that you won't necessarily find by people,
but you're far more likely to find,
find good people that way in that same token,
if you go around doing bad things to people, odds are bad things.
We'll find you eventually. That's how it Mo out works out for most people.
Makes me sad for her. Yeah. She strikes me just as a giant victim.
Not someone who acknowledges the fact that she is,
but someone who has been maybe victimized by people and wants to get away
from that fact. So they just do this to kind of seem strong,
but I might be wrong. And it is.
What it is because men who make more money than me,
they treat me with that same power dynamic. Right? Like I know that.
So that's fair. You think that that's okay. No, absolutely not. Okay.
But it's a way of life.
So because Richmond treats you badly. You want to treat people poor than you
and you want to keep dating rich men who treats you bad.
I have a question. I think who raised you.
Ne break it down for me. I.
Can't break it down. This makes no sense at all.
I, is this a classic case to hurt people, hurt people.
I really thought you what's about the, is it a really normal case of her piece?
<laugh>.
Maybe a little bit of that too.
<Laugh> yeah. I think it's a case of her, her people.
People she's a slight difference. I know hurt people, hurt people.
But then why was someone who gets hurt a lot,
going towards someone that she knows is gonna hurt them?
Maybe you can answer that one for me.
I don't have the answers way. I don't have the answers way. Yeah.
This is confusing. It's really weird. And the chat,
if you guys know the answer to this question, please,
we want to hear your comments below.
None of this makes sense.
This doesn't make sense, but we will allow her to speak her mind. I told you.
I would side chick myself to a rich. Why? Well, because I don't love a.
I'm gonna side chick myself too. So there has to be some incentive, right?
If I don't love you and your Dick is mediocre, why else would I be here?
So you're only here for the money. So you go dig if I'm a side. Yes. So you.
So you're a gold Digger.
I'm.
A side. Yeah. That's a culture that exists the side thing. Yeah.
Okay. I don't know. Maybe it's just me. Like, why would you want to,
there must be a psychological cost to who sell yourself to
a married man and deceit for money.
There's no way that you engage in that behavior that you know,
is morally reprehensible for money.
And there's not some kind of emotional scar that comes from that, you know?
Or maybe it's just lazy, man. Sometimes it can be that,
but some time it can be laziness. Hey, it's Warren. It's a form of, and again,
I don't got no problem with that. That's okay. This work is work. Whatever.
It's a form of that. Let's call it what it is.
If you give your body cuz being a side girl, side, chick,
side, whatever, uh, that's what it, you give your body in return.
You get you're a night Walker.
That's what it is. You're a night Walker. Yes. Okay.
Let's let's just call it what it is. All right. There's nothing wrong with it,
but that's what it is.
So it is really just a way of going by and making money and having incentive and
living a life. That's how I see it. Is it a bad thing? Hmm. Whatever.
There's no business business. So it is what it is. It's a,
this like another one to me. That's what I see. So you go.
There. If you have a side,
I want you to be as cautious of her as you are of me saying this, like,
I hope you don't ever think that you have a side who's just enamored with you.
You don't, you don't, she's there for an alternative resource.
So you make millions. Right. And I'm making a hundred thousand, okay.
You're going to treat me like an option, right? Like I have so much to prove,
to even get a ring, to even get a chance sometimes. Mm. A lot.
Unless my fat and my are big, which they're not. I'm sweet and I'm nice.
And I'm petite.
So I have a lot to prove is I have a lot to prove that being said,
I will treat a man who's broker than me the same way a man who's rich would
treat me. I have the control. I will cut you off. You can't move around.
And men don't like that. So I like, I like men who make more money than I do.
And it is what it is. I don't, I, I support my family. I support my household.
I have a child who's seven years old, happily living, whatever.
I absolutely will not support somebody else.
I don't even want you to make what I make. Because if you fall into a bad,
hard situation, I have to support you.
That's just really a case of hurt. People, hurt people. Like I said, like,
she's been hurt. She doesn't wanna go. She doesn't wanna hold down. Nobody.
Like she doesn't want a relationship.
And I don't think she believes in the relationship.
She doesn't believe in it like that. Unless there's money involved.
She's not in it for the love. She's not really in it for the relationship.
She's just in it for the option.
Let's be really clear with something being with someone,
one being married with someone or being like in a relationship with someone for
a long time. There's some benefits to that. If we take the love aspect out,
there's some benefits to that, right? That's of course,
if both people are pulling their weights, you know what I mean?
Some people are really just after that part and not the
companionship, not the love, not the, the is not that,
that it's really just the business side of things because it's a business
transaction, just the business side of things.
And the little bit side of it, that's how she view things.
She doesn't have any hope for relationship or stuff like that because she's been
probably shown bad examples and stuff like that.
Through the people above her generation, speaking the people,
her and in her own relationship, the errors that she did in the past,
or that's been done to her, whatever.
So she probably lost all the light, the interest, the life,
the beauty and all of that. She solely treats her relationship.
Like it's a business transaction and which is just, how is it gonna get me by,
you know what I mean?
And not with the love aspect because she doesn't believe in that.
The only thing that's gonna make her believe in that is if there's money
attached, but once the money's gone, it's gone. That's how, see, what do you.
Think about it?
I think you could sit here and systematically take apart.
A lot of her points, you know, the idea of like,
why would I support someone when they fall a hard time?
Even though they make more, same money as me, I wouldn't date them.
Cuz then if they fall apart, then I have to support them.
And if you fall apart, they would support you. But it is what it is.
I don't believe in that. She don't believe in that.
She believes that she deserves to be supported.
happens not the other way around. Okay. You know, there is your,
at the end of the day is just, it is just.
Sad. Sometimes your type is the reason why you're single.
And as someone who, who would make more money, if I met someone like that,
I probably wouldn't want to date them.
Absolutely. No.
No.
And it's not inherently because someone makes substantially more money than you.
That they're inherently going to treat you like you're constantly inferior.
Trust me. I know a lot of rich dudes who are whipped by their women.
I know a lot of dudes who aren't equal footing with their women,
despite an income disparity. It's not, not the way it works.
It's not the way it works.
It just so happens that you probably go after people who aren't for
you. And then you think that's how it is with all people who make more money.
Than you. You need to find what it is about your,
that that keeps attracting ancient.
KA Williams. Anyways, that was, uh, really weird to watch.
We wanna hear what you guys think of the comments below. That's it?